if you tried something and it didn't
work for you that's not a failure you
learned something
and that's positive momentum and so much
about
life is just about your mindset and how
you perceive things and whether you
let yourself get led down these rabbit
holes of negativity or whether you just
you know flip your perspective and go
actually learning opportunity
it's a challenge it's something i can
overcome i'm on the right path yeah
start to recognize those moments when
you spiral you know
it's a another great line by someone i
interviewed priyanka chopra
she said that sadness is seductive and i
was like oh
so tempting that's a good one it's like
there's something about
right just feeling like going down that
rabbit hole and looking at something on
the internet
totally and and really all it's doing is
is is fulfilling sort of like a hormonal
trigger loop where you just go to that
place
that is not necessarily good for you but
it's
familiar and so our bodies are so good
of being on good at being on autopilot
with so many things our subconscious is
programmed by the time we're like
six seven years old with most of the
things that exist in our life like
walking and talking and also our
emotional responses so
you talked about how you know you can
get into the
therapy and the other stuff and that's
also that's really hard and
and i want to talk about that because in
my opinion those are the roots
like the roots are when you go to
therapy in which i want to talk about
therapy too because i
i feel like i want to normalize therapy
because i feel like it's so helpful and
i want to normalize personal like solo
therapy i think there's so many people
that tend to
go to therapy because they're in a
relationship and things are breaking
down but
it's like you actually can solve a lot
or maybe all of the problem
if you all individually if you
individually go and work on yourself
because when you change the things you
see change and so exactly
it's not meant to be necessarily i think
like a codependent thing
although i think it's a tool later on
but you better be doing your own work
uh so i think that that that um that the
roots work
the childhood work and is so important
and you said it's hard and i just want
to talk about it being hard because
all i know for me is that everything
that has been a great transition in my
life
has come from like the fires of hell
like it is meltdown breakdown
convulsions
like you know just like true true
releasing
i mean that's all i can really call it
is releasing it's like
it's like alchemizing an old story and
burning it to the ground and like a new
one emerges
and yeah you have to for something new
it's painful i want you to talk about
the pain because
i i don't it doesn't yes it's really
hard but anything that you want to
achieve that's really great is going to
be hard so whether it's like a
transition into
a better better place in life mentally
or whether it's achieving like a bigger
bicep
like it's gonna it should be hard or
it's not true
right it's the same i mean it's that
whole idea that
breakdowns are actually breakthroughs
because if you've hit
a point in your life where you're at
this wall and then suddenly there's this
moment of confrontation within yourself
that means you're finally progressing
something
because the natural human instinct is to
run away from something difficult or
painful
and it's the same fear that can cause
people to procrastinate anything from
starting an essay if they're feeling
lazy about their homework oh i don't
want to do it i'm just going to play
video games
you're scared to start because you don't
want to do this difficult thing and
you're going to fail your class
you're not lazy you probably care about
what you're doing because you're scared
about it
it's just the fear that you need to
overcome for me it was that and then the
mental health you know i was like i just
after a long day after a really tough
week i don't want to do this hard work i
just want to
chill out and watch tv i don't want to
look in the mirror and go like what is
my trauma
i must overcome it but you have to and
i'm saying this is someone that has hit
those walls a couple times in my life
where i was just like you know what
for me the biggest thing was my
sexuality
because i knew from a very young age i
was probably some kind of gay
but i grew up in a very homophobic
environment super macho super aggressive
i went to an all boys school and
everything about it
indoctrinated me it was this
brainwashing that just said this is
something bad
this is something that will be bad for
you you have to just brush it under the
rug
and i went through decades of my life
just
deathly afraid of confronting this and
regardless of what you feel about it
it was the fact of who i am this is who
i am as a person i was made this way
and you can't hide from something like
that but trying to run from it
it just it drained away at every single
part of my life it pulled me down into
this depression it gave me fear
and paranoia of how i would be judged i
looked at myself in the mirror i hated
what i saw because i thought i was
fundamentally
broken and it got to this point where in
my life and career
i just felt like my life's a mess i
don't know what i'm doing but as this
person who's supposed to be this
performer
i can't step on a stage i can't turn on
a camera and tell someone about my day
when i know my entire life is built on
this lie that i'm telling myself
and i very dramatically i just
disappeared for like a year from the
internet because i was just like i
cannot
even create anymore i cannot bear to
open a little notepad file and then just
write a word because
every part of my body was just screaming
like you just can't do it anymore you
just can't do it i tried i tried i
really
tried to just brush it under the rug and
then it couldn't happen
and it took a year for me not just to
work out you know how i'm gonna tell my
family how is it gonna affect my career
how am i gonna
because you know the thing with coming
out until we live in a world where being
gay is completely uninteresting of
course it's going to be a big deal it's
a surprise so i was like oh no
even if i want to be the most
introverted left alone person it's going
to be this whole parade
when i you know have to break the news
about this thing
but even my own understanding of who i
was it took months for me to just look
in the mirror and be like look
you just need to accept that you're gay
it's just a fact so you need to learn to
deal with this
otherwise your life it just can't go
forward
and it's that whole you know people
don't want to go to therapy because
they're like
oh i'm scared i'm going to find out
there's a problem about myself and it's
like well yeah but
that's a good thing finding out that
you've got an issue is a great moment
when you get to the other side hey yeah
what is it what i mean i'm i'm i'm
curious and i'm sure that there are
people that will hear this and they're
in
they're in the position that you were in
um
like what is it what is it what is it
like to walk around and know that
no one knows or know that no one knows
for sure
and you know is it uh and and
and you know i'm fascinated with the
idea do you think that they can see you
like are you afraid like standing on a
stage is like
like does there always seem like there's
this sort of like
very thin veil between you know the
facade and the truth you know
and do are you afraid that maybe you'll
slip up i mean
what is it like to participate in your
own reality when it's not
the real thing i think that it's
actually
another quite universal experience that
anyone who feels like
uh yeah i know that my career is not
working out and i need to change
something or this relationship
yeah yeah yeah this could be i need to
make a change yeah this could be a lot
of people
you know they look at gay people and
they're like that's its own thing and
it's like actually it's the same thing
as you not wanting to have that
conversation with your wife you know
what i mean
and for me it was not only did it feel
like
i couldn't form any connection it was
putting an emotional wall up between
me and having anything real in my life
because
i wasn't letting anybody in or out and
then the
fear that there was this thing that
could just dissolve my entire life just
melt that
i felt permanently on edge and when i
say permanently
it's something that i experienced for
the entirety
of my life until the day i was like okay
well i guess i just have to clarify this
one little thing that may or not be
interesting
and when i say it felt like a weight
lifted
it's one of because i'm a very um you
know boring scientific
grounded person i'm not very uh you know
magical with my words or this that on
the other
but it felt like i had been wearing a
suit of chain mail
my entire life and the moment i
confronted the truth not just dealt with
it in the world but actually
just accepted it myself it just
instantly shared
and my physical feeling in my body and
perception of the entire world
changed instantly you cannot be
inauthentic in your life and it's one of
the most
difficult things that it's easy to say
you have to strive to be authentic in
every part of your life depending on
your circumstances
you might not be able to do that i
couldn't do it for so many years
it would have been great if i could have
magically done it as a child i just
wasn't in the position
whether you want to change your career
change your relationship come out or
something
sometimes you just have to bide your
time but you can't ever give
up on having that moment because you
know
we've all got this one life and i'm
saying as someone who's been on that
whole journey and got to the other side
whatever it is no matter how difficult
it is you gotta go that you gotta accept
the truth you gotta confront it and even
if it's really hard work
it's worth it yeah